there's something about embarrassment
that's i've competed a lot in my life
and i think the
if i'm too introspected the thing i'm
most afraid of is
being like humiliated i think nobody
cares about that
look you're the only person on the
planet zack cares about you being
humiliated exactly
it's like a really useless thought it is
it's like uh you're all humiliating
something happened in a room full of
people and they walk out and they didn't
think about it one more second
or maybe somebody told a funny story to
somebody else and then
throughout yeah that's yeah no i know it
too
i mean i've been really embarrassed
about [ __ ] that nobody cared about
myself
yeah that's a funny thing so the worst
thing ultimately is just
uh yeah but that's the cage and then you
have to get out of it yeah
like once you here's the thing once you
find something like that
you have to be determined to break it
because otherwise you'll just you know
slowly accumulate that kind of junk and
then you die as a
you know a mess so the goal i guess it's
so
it's like a cage within a cage i guess
the goal is to die in the biggest
possible cage
well ideally you'd have no cage
you know people do get enlightened i've
got a few it's great
you found a few there's a few out there
i don't know of course
um either that or they have you know
it's a great sales pitch there's like
enlightened people write books and doing
all kinds of stuff
it's a good way to solve a book i'll
give you that you've never met somebody
you just thought
they just kill me like this like
mental clarity humor no 100 but i just
feel like they're living in a bigger
cage
they have their own they still think
there's a cage they're still okay
you secretly suspect there's always a
kid ah there's no there's nothing
outside the the year there's nothing
outside the cage
you